[Music]
one of those exciting things that's
going on at NASA right now is that we
have a probe that's actually orbiting
very close to the Sun and over the next
year's it's going to get closer and
closer and closer it's called the Parker
solar probe and the catch phrase sort of
the mission motto is a mission to touch
the Sun and that sounds incredibly
dramatic I should probably quantify that
a bit we're not actually touching the
surface of the Sun but the Sun has an
atmosphere of gas around it I mean
almost like the earth has an atmosphere
it's called the corona and the corona
extends many millions of miles away from
the surface of the Sun Parker Solar
Probe is actually going to fly through
the corona getting into a fairly close
part now that doesn't sound so close
it's gonna get within about four million
miles away from the Sun but the Sun
itself is nearly a million miles across
about 900,000 miles across so this is
actually getting just about four times
the diameter of the Sun away which is
really pretty close it's by far the
closest object that humanity has ever
sent to the Sun over the next seven
years is gonna orbit around 24 times and
each time it's gonna get a little bit
closer to the Sun and in order to
survive that in order to have enough
speed to actually escape the Sun's
gravity and come out again it's gonna go
faster and faster all the time as well
so and it's fastest in a few years from
now the Parker Solar Probe will be going
nearly 400,000 miles an hour as it loops
around the Sun and then comes right back
out again that's by far the fastest
speed that any human-made spacecraft has
ever attained that's going to be very
exciting
so each perihelion is a little closer
and a little faster and then the orbit
takes it out close to the planet Venus
and the planet Venus actually helps
interestingly enough it helps Parker
lose energy in order to get closer and
closer to the Sun Parker has to lose
some of its own rotational energy and
when it loses energy can drop in a
little closer all the time so over the
next year's you're going to see our
spacecraft get a little closer each time
and go a little faster each time it goes
around the Sun now what are we looking
for why are we actually flying a
spacecraft as close to the Sun well the
corona the atmosphere around the Sun is
actually one of the biggest mysteries in
our solar system it's extremely hot the
gas around the Sun is
millions of degrees and that's rather
strange because the surface of the Sun
itself is only about 10,000 degrees so
how can the gas above the surface be
that much hotter than the surface itself
kind of the analogy we use at NASA is
picture yourself around a campfire at
night and you're enjoying the warmth of
the campfire but then as you walk away
from the fire
it becomes hotter and hotter as you go
away and burns you to a crisp five miles
out you know that doesn't work it's a
very strange way of thinking about
temperature so something's going on with
the corona it may have to do with the
sun's complex magnetic field
maybe the magnetic field is shooting
particles up into it it may have to do
with shockwaves even the Sun vibrating
actually giving energy to the gas above
it there's many different ideas and
theories as to why the corona is so hot
but right now we don't have a great way
to tell which is right and which isn't
so when we're there and actually
measuring how fast the particles are
going you know the different particles
you find how dense or how rarefied that
gases around the Sun we'll have a much
better idea which of those theories are
true the Parker Solar Probe to me is
also a marvel of modern engineering I
mean think about how are you gonna get a
spacecraft that close to the Sun and
have it survive and not burn up well the
whole spaceship is protected by a heat
shield the heat shield itself is not
very thick it's actually only about six
inches thick and it's made of a carbon
composite material with a very shiny
reflective aluminum coating on top
incredibly that heat shield is still
gonna get up to about 2,500 degrees
Fahrenheit so it's gonna get very very
hot but that will protect the rest of
the spacecraft from the radiation coming
from the Sun and the angle has to be
just right you always have to have the
heat shield right in between the Sun and
the rest of the spacecraft the rest of
the spacecraft has to be in its shadow
or it will fry and we actually can't
send commands up to Parker often enough
to make sure it's exactly lined up so
Parker is a very autonomous spacecraft
it's constantly detecting what its angle
is relative to the Sun and correcting
that so in some ways it's one of the
most autonomous spacecraft yet launched
one of the things I think is kind of
funny about the design is it does use
solar power that makes sense you're very
close to the Sun but it has these really
really dinky little solar panels off to
the side because when you're that close
to the Sun you don't need big solar
panels so at the end of Parker Solar
probes mission we will have this thing
orbiting closer to the Sun than we've
ever been before going faster than we
ever have before and maybe we'll finally
have some idea why this Corona this
mysterious million degree gas around the
Sun can possibly be that hot
[Music]